well let's fight about the abraham
accords you don't like the abrahamic
courts no not at all why not
well first of all they're not any kind
of peace deal
economic deals yeah the uae and bahrain
and sudan and morocco none of them were
at war with israel
uae and and sudan declared war on israel
in 67
but didn't send any troops but so these
aren't really peace deals what these are
is
sell out the palestinians on the
american pax
on the american taxpayers dime but
weren't weren't you saying before that
the trade deals with china would be
beneficial and help keep things
simmered down and prevent conflict sure
except there's just
hasn't been any conflict to prevent
between morocco and
it's is it's planes flying over
israel and flying over these countries
to and from i mean it's it's normalizing
economics it's like the first step
towards stabilizing the region
yeah but you had to buy a bunch of f-35s
for the uae in order to get them to do
it
and the real purpose of it is not
generating peace
and these guys have all been working
together with the israelis all along
anyway unofficially
what it really is is they're selling out
the palestinians because the palestinian
the deal had always been that these arab
states would not normalize relations
with israel until they gave the
palestinians an independent state
or equal rights within israel and they
didn't do that
and then what happened was jared kushner
went over there and said what's your
price
i have the american people's money in my
pocket i can spend as much of it as i
want
so what will it cost tim
but what were you doing to sell out the
palestinians i said well we'll take some
f-35s and we'll take some more of your
tax money and why should why should i
care about palestine
well muhammad atta crashed flight 11
into the north tower as revenge for what
the israelis were doing in palestine and
in lebanon
so it's actually an it's an argument for
us to not be involved
it's an argument for us absolutely to
not be involved but the thing is we
are involved the u.s backs everything
that the israelis do
so always have i i you know i i
mentioned this when you know cassandra
came on the show
came on the show country fairbanks she's
very anti-war and she was like
you're gonna hear a lot of propaganda
about why china's doing this that or
otherwise and we should not go to war
it's none of our business and i'm like
you know it's i don't really have an
argument for that it's like are we gonna
get involved in every single conflict
so for me it's like what can we do to
remove ourselves from these situations
to a to a greater degree as soon as uh
biden gets in the funding for for both
sides to various degrees resumes and
conflict
lights back up and that's good for
imperialism in the for the united states
it's an excuse now to put more military
into the middle east oh no it's
destabilizing oh there's war in conflict
instead we should just be like sure
maybe it cost money maybe we provided
weapons and stuff it's i don't know the
answers man i just know
under trump we were closer to getting
out of these these wars no new wars
and trump actually trying to pull troops
out and it was the establishment cronies
lying to the american people about the
troops in syria and trying to stop this
from happening
so i look at it like trade normalization
peace deals recognition of israel the
less
the less conflict the better and get our
troops out and be done with it
i think you're conflating separate
things together him trying to get out of
iraq and syria and afghanistan
is one thing his israel policy
was absolutely horrible and made
everything that much worse he recognized
israel's absolutely illegal seizure of
the golan heights
and their illegal annexation of it in
1981 and
said just on a whim i recognize it
officially now it's fine
then he moved the american embassy from
tel aviv
to jerusalem which is an important
symbolic move meaning that
america now recognizes all of jerusalem
as a single unified city under jewish
control
when the law says that east jerusalem is
illegally occupied by the israelis
and trump just said well screw that and
what that did was it negated even the
possibility of there being
an independent palestinian state with
east jerusalem as its capital
and it also raises the very important
question
of whether jewish extremists are going
to destroy the al-aqsa mosque and
rebuild the third temple and start
sacrificing animals and start world
war three i i think trump didn't care at
all about any of it
well he cared about sheldon adelson
giving him money for the republican
party
but sheldon adelson gave him what like
50 million dollars that's chump change
to donald trump he could have paid for
the entire his own entire re-election
and the entire republican party's
re-election and told sheldon adelson to
go to hell he said it was a mistake for
him to hire john bolton oh yeah
john bolton called him from shetland
sheldon adelson's office
in las vegas probably where i am right
now i want a job and trump gave him the
job that's right he should have told him
to go to hell
absolutely well he's dead now thank
goodness but he
was a extremely important mega donor
and hardcore zionist in america said his
only regret was that he joined the us
army instead of the idf
he said he is the one who publicly said
that obama should drop a nuke outside of
tehran
as a warning and if they don't obey
after that he ought to nuke the capital
city
and john's a total nut and john bolton
was the guy who said this time next year
we'll be celebrating in tehran
so the dude wanted to just invade and
people don't understand you can't
iran is not some tiny you know country
people understand
the the geographics but but uh i don't
uh i don't have all the answers so i
don't i i don't know everything about
all of these conflicts take a look at
what they did with morocco for this
abraham accord
as they call them all the abrahamic
courts i think it's originally only
bahrain and uae but then lump in sudan
and morocco
well morocco has been illegal occupying
the northern part of western sahara
for like 20 years and trump went yeah go
ahead you can have it
right so this is the liberal but hold on
rules based world order
that america is supposedly enforcing but
the rules don't apply to us
they don't apply to our friends we do
whatever we want the so the israelis are
in violation of the fourth geneva
convention
by transferring their civilian
population into occupied territory
oh well what's the geneva convention so
this is this is the problem
then should the united states just said
we're done with all of it we're out
bye-bye you have a nice day
absolutely and it's i'm sorry for
backing these criminals
against these helpless civilians this
population that
has been occupied for 54 years longer
than the soviets occupied
trump doesn't care about those other
countries that's right so there's
no going to trump and being like all he
cares about is america
all he wants is is the the border
secured and factory's back in america to
make america great
and so when you say yeah but these
people i don't know or care about any of
that
sign the deal get it done and get us out
of there we're out of it
no new wars trying to withdraw our
troops and they lied to keep them in
place
true so he also deliberately escalated
the war in afghanistan he deliberately
escalated the war
in syria until they finished iraq war
three against the islamic state there
but that's
right right escalated the war in somalia
and he took wherever there's um at the
war in
in yemen and the war in somalia he made
official
areas of active hostilities which under
the law
means that now the military and the cia
can kill
far more people than in more restrictive
circumstances where it's covert action
only
increase in drone strikes right massive
increase in in airstrikes drones and
planes in afghanistan and somalia and
yemen
and um he delegated the battlefield
authority
for the right to call in a strike as far
down the chain of command as he possibly
could
because when he came in there are all
these check boxes that obama and his
lawyers had added and they killed
tens of thousands of people with their
drone war but they had added all these
bureaucratic check boxes
but trump was raised on the myth of
vietnam and h.w bush talked about this
during iraq war one as well as
this was i don't know if you're familiar
with this but this was a big deal when i
was growing up
that lyndon johnson tied the hands of
the generals behind their back
nitpicking and pouring over the map in
the white house
and picking the targets himself and
controlling the policy and if
and if he hadn't done that then the
generals would have just done the right
thing
so trump said that's never going to
happen to me
no one is ever going to say that i
didn't let the military
have carte blanche to do whatever they
think is right in whatever
area and so when he came in he said i
want out of afghanistan it's in march of
of 2017. and when they were doing a
review and trying to get him to push to
escalate
and he said i hereby order all american
troops out of afghanistan and out of
south korea this is in the newest bob
woodward book
rage trump said this trump said this in
in three months into three months
into power two months into power and
james mattis the secretary of defense
that he hired
yep said belay that order yep we're not
leaving afghanistan and we're not
leaving korea and i don't give a damn
what the president said and then it was
three months later trump announced he
was sending another
10 000 men to afghanistan and massively
escalating the air war absolutely was
one of the biggest problems with trump
is that he hired a bunch of morons and
didn't fire the other morons
john bolton obviously and yes i think
the problem was
clearly it sounds like trump just said
we i wanna the american people want out
but he was he was surrounded by people
that he should not have trusted
and he gave them including bannon right
including his own people
right he couldn't trust he obviously
could not trust mcmaster
and mattis but he couldn't trust bannon
either and this is in
i forget if this is in fire and fury or
fear by woodward
one of the other of those i don't
necessarily trust the guy but well no
but it's it's horse's mouth stuff so
it's like
when mattis tells woodward and that's
when i said don't
do what the president said you can
pretty much believe that you know what i
mean
um is that treason and well certainly
it's criminal insubordination right i
don't know exactly what
you know which law in the military code
of unity
made the deal with mattis that listen
we'll shut up about afghanistan
if you guys promise to get worse on
china
and then mattis goes well sure we wanted
to build up against china anyway
and in exchange for that you're going to
shut up about afghanistan
deal and so it was bannon that sold out
trump on afghanistan just three months
into the thing and then they got rid of
him by what july
and then in august they announced the
big escalation yeah and then you know
there's a story in the post this also
comes from mattis straight out of the
horse's mouth
that in the washington post that trump
complained why are we in somalia
i don't even want to be in somalia where
is somalia
what are we doing in somalia and james
mattis told this ridiculous lie that
well we're trying to prevent a time
square attack
well the time square attack of 2010 was
direct retaliation
for the drone war in pakistan had
nothing to do with the somali
and drone strikes didn't prevent it
drone strikes
caused it okay but then but wait it gets
better then trump said no but i don't
care i don't want to be there i don't
understand why we have to be there
and mattis told trump quote you have
no choice and then what did trump do
he obeyed the secretary of defense
instead of saying actually i do have the
choice
you're the one who doesn't have a choice
mr secretary he said okay fine escalate
the war what do i care if they kill
another couple of ten thousand somalis
trump should have uh for one fired a lot
of morons not hired a lot of morons
and he should have just done he
why didn't he just go on public tv and
say this is the plan we're doing it look
i mean the truth is
it's because he doesn't read he doesn't
know anything right if he knew anything
at all tim
he would have gone to cato and he would
have gone to the national interest
and he would have said i want all of the
most credentialed anti-war right wingers
that you guys can line up for me let's
do this
think about how close we were honestly
if trump
in the first three months says out out
but he was too busy surrounding himself
by
bad people and special interests and he
was too busy complaining about
his crowd size at his inauguration and
every other stupid thing that didn't
matter at all and selling weapons to
saudi arabia to fund the yemen yeah
and so genocide basically yeah we'll get
to yemen in a minute but
i mean when he came in bannon said
here's our deal okay
we want uh to end all the free trade
agreements
we want to haul immigration from mexico
and we want to end all the wars
well guess what trump has total power
over one of those issues
the wars right and that's all he had to
do was
say i really mean this i'm really
sticking with this
we are ending these wars and if he done
that
it also would have been absolutely
brilliant politics
throwing a nuclear hand grenade into the
democratic party
and making the liberals attack him from
the right for ending wars
and convincing the leftists well they
never hated liberals so much
they did that right the media absolutely
did that they were claiming that trump
was
you know leaving was irresponsible and
it was a gift to these dictators and
isis and clearly trying to negotiate
peace was just him appeasing dictators
and all that stuff
teasing putin that was you know what i
love this one you can check this in the
washington post
everybody go check in the washington
post everybody in
june it was june or july of 2017
trump ordered an end to the cia program
backing the al-qaeda terrorists the
al-nusra front aka
hyatt tahrir al-sham in syria and the
washington post headline
reads in move sure to please vladimir
putin
trump orders end of covert action
program in syria so
they accuse him of treason for stopping
a program of arming al qaeda
terrorist suicide bomber head chopper
murderers thanks for checking out this
clip from the tim cast irl podcast
if you want to see the full show come
back to this
channel youtube.com tim cast irl
monday through friday at 8 p.m where you
can leave comments
and super chat and we actually will read
your comments
on the show don't forget to like share
subscribe and if you want
exclusive members only content segments
you can't get anywhere else
go to timcast.com become a member and we
even have full bonus episodes
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time
you